que faut-il penser de la stratégie de la
dîmière poutine en ukraine on sait que
le renseignement est un élément
important de toute opération militaire
on sait aussi que poutine est un ancien
du kgb alors j'ai parlé un peu plus tôt
à servir 9 c'est un ancien espion du kgb
qui a brièvement connu l'admirent
poutine il vit en france depuis 2001 en
tant que réfugiés politiques et vient de
faire paraître lutte l'erreur cette
biographie on écoute
mais si j'en avais un bon soir bienvenu
24 60
alors commencer un espion du kgb vous
gaver connu vladimir poutine au sixième
jour de cette guerre qui prend fin mais
le 7e ou la septième nuit à venir
bientôt on craint évidemment le pire
notamment à kiev mais croyez-vous que
vladimir poutine est frustré humilié des
scénarios auxquels on assiste en ce
moment puisqu'il n'a toujours pas
rencontré ses objectifs
oui je crois le corps parce que c'est
une personne qui est qui est une
personne assez particulièrement assez
particulière au niveau psychologique
donc bien évidemment je crois donc tout
le monde qu'il a acquis la sous-estimer
la possibilité de résistance des
ukrainiens et la surestimer la
possibilité de conquérir le cren donc il
est plus chaud frustré ouais et quel est
le rôle du renseignement soit le
renseignement russe tout même le
renseignement ukrainiens ou même d ali
sur le terrain dans cette guerre
fratricide
dans toutes les guerres le renseignement
joue un rôle très important parce que ça
permet de bien planifier les frappes
pour celui qui qui qui frappe et de bien
planifier la défense que ce pot celui
qui se défend en revanche il ya autre
chose qui se passe avec poutine et son
renseignement j'ai l'impression qu'ils
lui donnent pas la voix le vrai
renseignements mais il lui donne ce
qu'il veut entendre parce que je sais
par où au canada vous n'avez pas vu
cette scène le 21 février quand il avait
le conseil de guerre de poutine où il a
humilié
narychkine le chef du svr et on a
compris qu'en fait il avait une relation
très particulière avec le renseignement
d'éventuellement politique vous avez
compris il le met le mépriser et donc
elle à emilie publiquement donc çà çà çà
vous démontre aussi que la relation avec
poutine avec les gens qui travaillent
dans leur raisonnement n'est pas si
simple que ça et même avec ses généraux
on a vu des regards des yeux se ferment
et des paupières se fermer devant le
l'ordre de poutine donc et croyez vous
qu'il puisse y avoir autour de lui une
certain que ce soit au niveau du kgb ou
nouveau dégénéré une certaine dissidence
qui s'installe parce que on juge cette
guerre injustifiée
de toute façon cette guerre est
injustifiée et il ya beaucoup de gens
autour de lui à mon avis qu'il croyait
mais qui n'osait pas le dire surtout
dans le renseignement qui savait aussi
que cette guerre ne peut pas être gagnée
d'ailleurs par rapport à ça il faut
citer le général leonid ivashov c'est
l'ancien chef de la direction générale
de la coopération internationale
militaire au ministère de la défense qui
le 31 janvier trois semaines avant
l'attak a publié une lettre ouverte les
dix meilleures poutines au nom de
l'association panne russe des officiers
y danse est dans cette déclaration il a
d'abord dit que cette guerre n'a pas ne
doit pas être menée que les militaires
ne veulent pas l'amener que la russie
n'a pas les moyens de la mener que
poutine doit démissionner de son poste
de commandant en chef que tous les
officiers doivent ne doivent pas exécuté
les ordres qui le client qui sont les
ordres criminels et que si jamais
poutine commencé cette guerre d'abord il
ne pourra jamais la gagner et ensuite
c'est de guerre sera la perte de la
fédération de russie et pourquoi pas
vous montrer que oui mais pourquoi il ne
peut pas la gagner cette manière la
supériorité de la russie est tellement
plus grande que celle de l'ukraine et
l'otan n'intervient pas sauf en
fournissant des armes
il ne peut pas la gagner parce que la
supériorité militaire ne
ne régit pas tout je peux vous rappeler
que la super y étaient des américains
qui combattent et au vietnam était peut
être cent fois supérieur à la supérieure
à la force militaire des vietnamiens
c'est pourtant c'est les vietnamiens qui
ont gagné de la guerre la supériorité
soviétique en afghanistan était mille
fois supérieur aux afghans pour tancer
les soviétiques ont perdu cette guerre
la super y étaient russes étaient
peut-être dix ou cent fois plus que la
supériorité des tchétchènes pour tancer
les tchétchènes qui ont gagné cette
guerre parce que contrairement à ce
qu'il raconte poutine la russie a perdu
la guerre anti ni anti tignères nous
avons actuellement à rally for islamiste
dirigée par ramzan kadirov qui est un
djihadiste islamiste et les lois russes
ne fonctionne pas en russie et la loue
et la russie paye à la tchétchénie à une
redevance entre 1 milliards et 5
milliards de dollars par an en même
temps on a mobilisé semble-t-il 4,5
tchétchénie plus pour venir supporter
l'invasion des l'ukraine padule pas
justement justement c'est ça en fait c
est 1 c c'est le contrat que poutine a
passé avec avec kadirov donc en fait il
a reconnu de fait la de l'indépendance
de tchétchénie kadyrov fait dans la city
ce qu'il veut en revanche quand poutine
a besoin pour faire une sale besogne
fédéraux et poutine d'une chose selon
certains observateurs et fait le
contraire il ya un convoi qui serait à
l'arrêt au porte de kiev les choses
pourraient changer mieux quand même des
bombardements importants aujourd'hui la
station de télévision qui a coupé la
diffusion des émissions est juste à côté
ce mémorial de l'holocauste c'est un
paradoxe assez incroyable mais donc
s'est tenue pour être terré dans leur
poutine fait ça mais en même temps et on
est à la veille de négociations
poutine est il fiable est ce que ça vaut
la peine de s'asseoir avec sa délégation
poutine n'a jamais été fiable dans les
dents dans les négociations poutine est
un manipulateur et un menteur
patenté d'ailleurs en aussi nous avons
un petit dicton populaire qui dit si
vous voyez à la télévision poutine à
bouger les lèvres c'est qu'il est en
train de mentir donc en fait nous les
russes on n'a pas énormément de
croyances et de hongrois poutine sincère
en revanche vous savez ce qui se passe
avec les négociations les négociations
avec poutine actuellement et sont plus
importantes pour l'occident pour le
monde entier parce que je pourrais les
comparer à aux pourparlers que mène un
psychiatre avec un malade mental qui est
en train de faire une crise
une crise de démence c'est aussi on peut
la comparer à des pourparlers que mènent
les gens de ce fait ce naze lorsque il
ya un forcené qui a pris des otages est
donc gagné 0 il faut mener avec ce
forcené les au talent avant d'enclencher
le lasso et donc c'est pour parler ça
perdre ça permet aussi vous savez ce qui
se passe alors au kremlin poutine a
construit un système dans lequel il n'y
a plus personne qui lui dit la vérité il
est complètement
coupée de la vérité et il est dans sa
bulle et les seules personnes qui
peuvent encore lui raconter ce qui se
passe réellement ce sont les dirigeants
étrangers donc il faut garder cette
ligne rouge pour lui rappeler tout
simplement la réalité de l'autre côté le
renseignement américain c'est le pain
tamment pentagone qui annonce
aujourd'hui qu'il ya des unités russes
qui font défection et qui sabotent même
leur équipement militaire qu'est ce que
c'est un ans selon vous
c est une bonne annonce d'ailleurs on a
eu sa même avant d' attaque parce que
les premières les premières informations
deux défections et nous sommes parvenus
deux jours avant le commencement de la
taxe c'est à dire tout de suite après la
proclamation du 21 février mais avant le
24 le début des opérations parce que
dans ces unités il ya des appelés
mais il ya aussi des contractuels et
donc les gens qui étaient les
contractuels lorsqu'ils ont compris
qu'ils allaient être envoyés dans un
pays où il n'y a aucune or aucune motive
aucune motivation pour faire une guerre
donc ils ont compris qu'il fait qu'elle
était peut-être temps d'abandonner cette
gare parce que il est risqué de se
retrouver après comme des
criminels de guerre parce qu'il faut
bien rappeler que cette guerre c'est une
guerre criminelle le cren n'a jamais
rien fait contre la russie
l'histoire de l'otan c'est une histoire
complètement inventée par poutine parce
que le temps non plus n'a jamais
combattu contre la russie le temps
possède déjà les bases en turquie depuis
lesquelles depuis ses bases il peut
atteindre toutes les toutes les cibles
que poutine a dénommé quand il disait
que le rapprochement de l'otan va causer
une énorme avancée a le temps donc si
vous prenez par exemple l'estonie et la
turquie le temps peut attendre tout ce
qu'il peut tout ce qu'il veut avant les
monts oural ans aussi donc tout ça c'est
du c'est bidon et est donc voilà il faut
il faut oublier tout ça et d'ailleurs
cette guerre poutine là mais uniquement
pour punir le peuple ukrainien qui est
un peuple libre qui est un peuple
démocratique et qui est un peuple et qui
a voulu choisir le modèle européen est
le modèle civilisée de développement ce
a renvoyé sa renvoyé à poutine une image
qui lui était dégradante parce que c'est
une image quasiment accusatrice parce
que lui il est là depuis 22 ans et il
pense rester encore 14 ans est donc bien
évidemment il ne pouvait pas supporter
ça et puis l'ukraine a acheté par à deux
reprises le protégé de poutine
ianoukovitch la première fois quand
poutine l'a présenté la wii le cren ne
va pas élu la deuxième fois ils ont ils
eu mais ils ont renversé une 2014 et
donc du coup poutine qui est qui et qui
est quelqu'un qui est très rancunière
rancunier quelques est quelqu'un qui est
présent très peu sûr de lui donc qui
punit les ukrainiens uniquement pour ça
la russie n'a pas besoin de territoire
la russie possède 17,5 millions de
kilomètres carrés ce territoire russe à
deux tirs n'est pas développé on a pas
de route on a on a encore des bâtiments
stalinien on a encore des bâtiments même
d'avant la révolution d'octobre la
russie possède toutes les richesses qui
lui qu'il lui faut là non plus il n'a
pas besoin de documents les richesses
surtout que l'ukraine ait plus pauvres
par rapport à la russie donc pour
poutine il ya aucune motivation
pragmatique de mener cette guerre là ce
programme à la seule motivation bodo
poutine c'est une vengeance personnelle
n'as-tu sergey géré 9 merci beaucoup
d'avoir parlé ce soir depuis la france
et j'espère qu'on pourra se reparler et
que les choses évolueront dans un bon
sens pour d'histoire et la paix merci à
vous
toutes façons oui merci notre statut
poutine ne peut pas la gagner cette
guerre ouais mon résultat là bas en
espérant vous avez raison merci beaucoup
on se reparle merci vraiment la rage
c'est une indication c'est très généreux
de votre part merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit